gg 118 ans dans quelques jours je
religieuse parce que le banc devant
voulu human bomb il est
une façon parfaite
[Musique]
c'était la guerre on a eu très peur de
la loi de mauvaises nouvelles j'avais un
frère qui malheureusement a été blessé
et un qui est revenu cinq sens et qui
s'était engagé à 18 ans il a été
officier gens et j'ai pu fiers de leur
pays est en france c'est mérité la
valeur de 2 aujourd'hui à 10h revenu
j'avais
16 ans alors j'ai été heureux comme tout
[Musique]
on
aime pas mais assure que religieuse
parce que le banc devant vous lima human
bomb in et une façon parfaite je ne
trouvais pas à aimer infos que j'ai
fréquenté
les choses religieuses et toujours barde
un choix à un moment donné je dis ma
voix ma voix je vais être religieuse et
chari moi j'aimais le bon dieu par
dessus tout il m'a bien rendu
[Musique]
pour les enfants j'en ai fait beaucoup
beaucoup mais peut-il me manque et où
vous savez pas être que j'ai retrouvé
le plus jeune qui a un qui à 80 ans je
n'apprécie que
personnellement moi
alors j'aime bien les gens qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées
sinon c zéro en jeu rend pas compte de
ce qu elles ont fourni
que le beau jeu bourquin gens donnaient
à leurs familles à georgette réseau ça
oui
[Musique]
oh non je ne peux pas gagner
je n'ai pas du tout envie mon désir
c'est de mourir et de mai et de trop
rendre mon frère non non j'ai pas eu
peur d'abord un jeu je crois que l'homme
je peux me faire confiance aubry je ne
sais pas si mauvais confiance mais je
sais qui il tarde à l'énergie impression
j'ai oublié je le lui dis toujours
[Musique]
vous savez la droite ou la gauche ça me
charger part je n'appréciais que les
gens je ne me mets pas du président de
la république à ce moment là je m'occupe
une main petit charles de gaulle oui je
suis allé voir sa maison et 100 femmes
et les tirs sans fin et manquait
toujours après j'aime bien j ce cadre
[Musique]
c'est pour qu'elle joue romain c'est
pour le figaro ma soeur a entièrement
ses bons jours ils sont beaux c'est bon
le figaro
[Musique]